[Musica]
quale autonomi cose vi è venuto famosa
chi è super meat boy
ed ecco appunto siamo arrivati al
livello di handler credo che sia la fine
ragazzi anche se dopo c'è una roba
strana che hanno capito cos'è però vabbè
[ __ ] importante essere arrivati
quando ho sentito di end e io credo sia
alla fine perché sono col cazzo sei figo
non sappiamo il tiro sappiamo mi stupra
la donna mi ha lanciato la donna addosso
di end ho capito è solo 5 veramente sono
cinque livelli a perché si vede che
gliel'ha data la tizia quest'anno era
non sarebbe stato così magnanimo allora
che se partiamo col primo non so che
cosa
immagino che siano impossibili se sono
solo 5 in realtà è una stronzata ragazzo
che sono scemo comunque rea perché fatto
che che non mi sembra così ma in realtà
devo fare questi cinque poi io ho finito
il gioco la pancia farò mai quindi non
mi pongo questo problema e vai vai un
pene di gomma a miseno una chiave mica
un casino credo che serve al manuale di
istruzioni dell'ikea per finire si
livelli qua impossibile c'è una chiave
qua perfetto più aperto che cazzo aperto
lega anno a non sempre su questo tana
tua madre tranquilli ragazzi ce la
faccia non vi preoccupate che con
l'apecar messa mentale risolviamo tutto
perfetto mossa billo tua madre che
l'autostrada e servono per andare in
macchina non per battere ok no no no va
perché ma perché ma perché ci tieni
proprio a farmi diventare i [ __ ]
quadrati zio fa micah p no perché devo
capire queste cose sennò non hanno
l'assenso piano ok ok se stavo anche
cadendo story cadendo
ok no ma non è ke kazzo salvini che
potevo fare un attentato in piazza duomo
se motivo così si ok ok e sono due sono
due ragazzi non mi ricordo dove anche i
doveri e in tornei dove prima non ce la
farò mai nella vita però ci proviamo
ragazzi si no si ok
sì sì
oddio oh mio dio siamo alla fine nel
dubbio ragazzi aprite la finestra che se
credo adesso dovreste sentire un urlo
che viene da fuori sono io da milano ok
ma cos'è ma io come li faccio 5
preferivo fare 200 livelli più semplici
che 5 così è assurdo sono stati proprio
bastardi nel midollo osso barra che
merda di gioco come un peso morto prima
fatemi capire ci prova regala ormai ci
posso senza pensare [ __ ] non ce la
farò mai
io sono ancora il primo livello il primo
livello ancora il primo livello e sono
passati cinque anni
sì o dio
oddio oddio ok go com come ho fatto ma
cos'è ma così
ma cos'è la cosa ho fatto va beh va bene
va bene ok ho vinto sono bravo sono
bello sul fotomodello sof javier
giovincello bravissimo siamo arrivati a
livello 2 è che bello metterla qua sopra
infarti assaporare il fatto che ci sta
qua e non la prenderei mai mi faccia
salire poi di nuovo importante
l'importante che riusciamo a scendere
per adesso poi va bene perfetto ok dove
il cazzo vado ok perfetto va bene piano
piano sono vivo sono il perfetto
perfetto live by sea la chiave celo celo
celo ok in quella che mi fa vedere anche
che sia aperto il passaggio la tua madre
si apre lo stesso anche senza che la
veda tornare indietro e non so come non
fatemi domande non ne ho idea ok è di
qua
cazzola dai forza forza
torniamo qui è fin qua e fin qua va bene
ma che cazzo farmi prego in turco arslan
brand che funziona a pregare in turno
bravissimo perfetto ok ho detto ci siamo
quasi ragazzi ci siamo siamo ancora
indietro come cazzo si fanno da navarca
di una vacca ladra ok
ok ho l'ho fatta sono fatta sì o mio dio
mio dio mio dio cosa ho fatto
ragazzi va bene non voglio mai più nella
vita rifare questa non lo voglio neanche
più vedere il suo cazzo di livello va
bene così c'è una roba adatto sto
facendo studiare lo senza neanche sapere
come ha fatto cioè così a caso effetto
non mi ha preso non mi ha preso va bene
a regà non ci credo oddio un orologio
questa una merda una merda una merda
devo andati sotto di sotto di sotto
impossibile se ci vuole un genio per
fare sta roba io non sono di certo un
genio però lo faccio uguale cazzo cazzo
cazzo cazzo cazzo perché devo lanciare
le cuffie ogni volta mi han e spontanea
stavo per vincere l'altra senza neanche
averlo mai giocato fantastica e vai vai
salta stronzo salta come se avessi una
mamma salta nuova perché la manco ma
cazzo potevo farne a meno magari invece
no invece tua madre si può parlamento sì
l'ho presa o mio dio
io mi sono emozionato della pelle d'oca
vai vai vai vai dove ci sono ancora due
chiavi da dove cazzo le prendo come se
non devo anche tornare india e bello mi
piace questo gioco non seriamente
commenti esplodo la famiglia è un film
guardalo hd quella mia air quella chiave
amica è chi l'aveva vista ma dai ma io
ragazzi vi giuro non avevo mi capisca
cio è pendente ragazzi avevo vinto se
avessi visto le chiave prima avrei vinto
pezzo madonna
ma [ __ ] se sì sì il mio addio al
quarto ragazzi quarto è bravo zio no
bravo bravo no no e allora minchia è
tutto così sto livello dove passare le
lame sì come gli emo bravo bike bravo
perfetto giu
sì cazzo madonna come sto facendo io non
lo so va bene
gli ultimi due stanno andando da dio non
so come forse forse adesso muoio però
potrei morire ai ragazzi potremmo dire
potrei incazzarmi invece no invece no
invece no oddio punta merda c'è va beh
come farcitura andare a culo in una
maniera primo [ __ ] tentano secondo al
secondo tentativo ma scherziamo sono
veramente ragazzi sono rimasto scioccato
impossibile vabbè va bene va bene va
bene baba bene non ho veramente capito
come ho fatto a non è possibile
e assurdo
ma se non ci arriva neanche cazzo di
lame
aiutaci e non si può fare che cosa devo
fare spiegamelo dimmi almeno cosa vuoi
che faccia sì o cazzo ci sei arrivato
soriato bene e costante non salto come
non ci arrivo invece si può dire mi sono
emozionato ho le lacrime
certo che se vuoi la mia vita tu ok ma
ho capito
va bene va bene bravo bravo dove vado io
vado non ci passa fontana mangia di meno
cazzo vitasnella traffico ci passa da
dentro e non vorrei dire bravo bravo
complimenti bravissimi sì o dio
oddio la chiave dove nemmeno infilo cosa
me ne faccio saltare in mezzo ce l'ho
fatta non parole
non ho visto da piano ragazzi ma che
merda come ho fatto prima
sì sì l'ho presa e l'ho presa
oddio come se come scendo come cazzo
uscendo no doc d'oca sì sì sì ok che
cosa facciamo ragazzi
ragazzi si mancano mancano delle lame
ragazzi oddio
se come in mutande ma [ __ ] vai
così cazzo ma è chiaro che merda madonna
madonna con gli amici
guarda che me una colonia ragazzi ci ho
messo gli anni per far sta con non ci
posso credere io mio vai avanti gesù non
ci posso credere mai mossa l'ot ma
[ __ ] anni per fare sta cosa
ragazzi gli anni che è successo dove
ecco bastardo di mezzi intimorisce la
famiglia non usata pure neanche sono
morto vai phoenix ma come vista spara
quante volte mi sta sparando alto
stimando fantastico
aspetto vai vai vai super meat boy mi
trovai meat boy ci penso io mi vuoi
cos'è
ma sono proprio contro gli [ __ ]
intanto non i colpi li tolga forse sì
devo andare avanti nel mentre che lui mi
spara tentando di vincere il livello
fammi capire da lui non lo beccano le
lame bastardo del cazzo è la madonna che
il casinò c'è una roba isis molto isis
bravo bravo entra e rossi milano non lo
assimila a lui legame non gliene frega
un cazzo le bravo della serie la legge è
uguale per tutti zio bravissimo tutto
figlio di [ __ ] guardali è
impossibile sono fatta
cazzo cazzo ci sto facendo a caso è
stato un suicidio kamikaze sono tornato
guai veloce veloce veloce dai quanto è
lungo sto livello giusto per chiedere le
curiosità ragazzi no io mi sono salvato
se sabato sono salvato addio addio pausa
pausa ho bisogno di capire
oh mio dio ma vabbè allora allora io ce
l'ho fatta ma non ci credo
lui sta andando ragazzi aiuto cazzo vado
io
dove vai e niente dove vai doveva doveva
tua madre quando va comprando e per e
doveva l'ho fatto come cazzo fatto da
quel giorno ti fa vj non si ebbero più
notizie del giornale la nasa le nonne in
calore tutti tutti cerchiamo di dare una
spiegazione alla sparizione di questo
ragazzo un gioco semplice ed io un po la
merda è stato in grado di fare tutto
questo fa vj dov'è finito lo scoprirete
nel prossimo episodio di super figlio di
[ __ ] boy
a presto